est ce qu'il ya une heure pour boire de
la bière ans je pense que non 1975 la
bière ce bois fraîche blonde et donc à
toute heure à cette époque la bière
boisson de soif bat tous les records en
1976 par exemple année de grosse chaleur
en moyenne un français abus 49 litres de
bière mais passée la canicule la bière
perd de sa superbe
la boisson reste cantonné à une boisson
industriel pas cher une bonne bière doit
être claire et brillante
le buveur incline le vert en ne touchant
pas à la mousse ce film est blanche
plaisir des dieux un soupçon d'amertume
sur le pal
cette boisson industrielle au goût
uniforme et délaissé des français
regardez cette courbe en 1988 il buvait
10 litres de moins par an qu'en 1976
alors pour endiguer cette désaffection
les industriels tentent de conquérir une
nouvelle clientèle
kronenbourg s'attaque aux femmes dans le
cadre de sa politique de diversification
le premier brasseur français lance
chronique c'est le nom d'une boisson
destinée tout particulièrement au sexe
dit faible
le travail de reconquête des clients va
durer plus de 30 ans des bières fruitées
pour les femmes mais aussi un changement
d'image avec des bières - industriels
plus artisanale est bonne
et un petit plus en bray que la bien
ordinaire mais ça ne tire pas sur la
bière bruit et le pari fonctionne alors
que la consommation d'alcool baisse en
france ces dernières années
la bière est la seule boisson à voir sa
consommation augmenter en 2018 un
français buvait 33 litres de bière par
an et en est loin de la blonde légère
les gens qui ont écouté ça une fois dans
leur vie peuvent pas revenir en arrière
chercher une bière dans le supermarché
un peu fade pas très très agréable c'est
fini les bières artisanales ont permis
cette remontée ada de la petite mousse
entre 2018 et 2019
une micro brasserie est lancé chaque
jour dans l'hexagone et malgré ça les
français restent des petits buveurs face
à leurs voisins européens
ils sont en effet les avant-derniers
buveurs de bière de l'union européenne
[Musique]